[Musique]
je suis très heureux parce qu'on va
parler musique on va parler jazz on va
parler aussi pop rock pop anglaise avec
Sandrine con bonjour bonjour euh vous
êtes chanteuse et de pas n'importe quel
groupe c'est de l'adrian Clark trio et
d'avrid pouradiier duail bonjour bonjour
Vous ê le batteur et un peu l'âme aussi
de de ce trio hein alors j'en ai deux
sur trois oui oui parce que le Damien
argentierie est un peu plus faignant que
vous quoi ouais il aime pas se lever
pour la télé et non ben il travaille
déjà s voilà c'est le plus sérieux
d'entre nous il est déjà il est déjà en
train de répéter il il est au turbain il
est turb ou alors faut dire qu' il y a
une actualité euh bah presque immédiate
c'est c'est vendredi vendredi c'est le
vendredi 13 c'est un vendredi 13 he
absolument vous êtes superstitieux ou
pas vous bah ça dépend dans quel sens le
bon ou le mauis ça porte bonheur ah je
pense que les concerts ça porte bonheur
quel que soit la DAT de toute façon et
et vous êtes pas les seuls parce que
c'est donc au théâtre d'odé à coignère
ouais et ben c'est plein ben oui ben oui
donc donc donc voilà les gens se disent
pas oh là et oui oui un affiche complet
effectivement ben oui c'est c'est super
on est Rav bon voilà comme on n pas
besoin de faire de promo merci au revoir
salut c'est gentil d'être venu c'est
gentil d'être venu ça sert à rien quoi
si il a d'autres dates il y a d'autres
dates absolument alors d'abord et alors
vous êtes bourgignon je suis bourgignon
ouais absolument et vous allez all en
Bourgogne faire le spectacle alors nous
jouons ce spectacle le 10 18 novembre
prochain à
mceau pied des vignes voilà donc
histoire de de se donner quelques
couleur vous allez boire un peu vous
buvez un peu avant oh non que de l'eau
nous que de
l'eauprè aprs après vous pouvez ouais
mais c'est vrai qu'on est très moi je
suis très sensible au vin blanc je le
dis B mceau pas mieux onoue donc ça ça
sera le 18
novembre mais oui voilà je dis ça c'est
les gens peuvent être en weekend
je ouais je crois bien qu'ils ont choisi
la date en fonction de la soirée des des
hospices de bon c'est des hospices de B
les ventes les vent c'est ce weekend là
c'est le même weekend du coup ils on mon
avis ça va être assez compli aussi et
ben après on pourra pourra attendre le 3
février oui alors là vous êtes à Guill
encour à la patterie à l'udutorium ouais
on joue à deux pas vraiment d'ici on
joue le samedi 3 février il y a en
double plateau il y a un groupe qui
s'appelle del
Yaman le même soir et et euh et nous on
sera là donc à l'auditorium de la
batterie c'est une super belle salle
super belle salle ouais qui fait partie
de de de ce complexe de ce pôle musique
à guillancour qui est qui est qui est
génial il y a un conservatoire il y a il
y a une salle musique actuell il y a un
restaurant il y a des locaux de
répétition il y a un super auditorium et
cetera ça et c'est là vous serez et
c'est là qu'on sera 3 février samedi 3
tris et puis après il y aura le 30 av
Meon enfin bon voilà de toute façon vous
avez un site don on pour retrouver oui
on a un site après on est un peu plus
actif sur les réseaux sociaux enfin
voilà sur sur sur Facebook Instagram
mais les dates sont annoncées ouais on
va on va parler de ce spectacle parce
que c'est le nouveau spectacle là vous
sortez de de quelques mois avec un
spectacle nouaro hein c'était le le
dernier spectacle vous savez tout bah je
l'ai vu
et c'était vachement bien B merci ch
bien Sandrine he ah oui oui bah oui
c'est je dis pas que vous battez mal
mais non mais non mais moi moi je fais
figure un peu de le batteur il est il
est le c'est un vrai on en avait
longuement parlé la dernière fois que
m'avie on a parlé du métier de de
batteur de l'importance de la batterie
d'ailleurs moi je catalyse les les les
choses les les ambiances pas seulement
le le rythme en fait c'est ça bien sûr
bien sr bienû c'estàdire il il y a le
rythme je suis le je suis le gardien de
de ça je suis le garant et puis il y a
les couleurs harmonique de Damien il y a
la mélodie de pour Damien argenti
pourquoi un or pourquoi pas par exemple
un piano ça existe aussi dans les
trios disons qu'un piano seul enfin
piano batterie voie il va nous manquer
un peu de un peu de basse voilà et
puis la main voilà nous on a découvert
on on s'est rencontré tous les trois sur
un spectacle en Bourgogne justement déjà
il avait déjàel
et Damien argentier il était sur tous
les claviers euh et c'est vrai qu'on a
eu cette cette envie tout de suite bah
déjà de tous les trois se rencontrés
musicalement mais humainement et puis
bah on s'est trouvé bien à 3 on n' pas
eu envie de faire rentrer quelqu'un
d'autre donc ce qui nous laisse aussi
oui be par exemple ça ça manque moins
que si c'était il j fait en fait il jou
la main gauche en fait c'est ça le le le
c'est ça fait une espèce de de double
emplo en fait il joue deux instruments
c'est ça en permanence voulez voulez
qu'on VO alors on va voir un petit
extrait pour voir à quoi à quoi ça
ressemble le le trio alors il faut
préciser hein c'est pas le spectacle que
vous allez jouer à partir de vendredi
hein c'était même pas le le spectacle
numéro c'était un peu avant c'est le
spectacle d'avant c'est çaou alors on a
c'était encore un autre spectacle ouais
en gros on on en est à notre 4e ou 5e
répertoire depuis qu'on existe VO on va
regarder un petit extrait pour voir à
quoi quo ressemble l'adrian clar
[Musique]
trio
[Applaudissements]
voilà ça on l'a vu hein c'était dans une
église ben ouais dans l'église de poise
poère ouais ouais 2018 déjà en fait le
le le programmateur de la de
l'association président de l'association
de des amis de l'org à coinière nous
avait très habilement et très très
malicieusement coincé gentiment coincé
en nous disant bah écoutez nous on adore
votre trio mais c'est vrai que avec le
le public qui est plus ferru de
classique euh peut-être que si on comme
ça on plaque un concert entier de jazz
et il nous a mis la puce à l'oreille
comme ça alors que par contre si vous
nous jouez des petites choses un petit
bout de de répertoire du classique avec
votre façon de de réharmoniser les
choses en fait il nous a mis sur un
plateau l'idée en fait c'est lui et du
coup on s'est pris au jeu on a fait ça
et c'est de la même façon qu'on a qu'on
a joué le nouaro nouaro ça s'est fait de
la même manière en fait quelqu'un nous a
dit bah tiens on aime bien le trio mais
si vous nous faisiez du nouaro ça serait
sympa alors là ça s'appelle dance let's
dance let's dance
voilà remarque tu as raison parce que
let's dance on est plutôt son côté
britishage oui c'est ça la pop rock
anglaise comment vous avez choisi alors
euh et
bien ça remonte euh ça remonte un peu
pendant le le confinement
où on était confiné et un peu confi
aussi euh on a réfléchi à pas mal de de
choses qu'on avait envie de faire alors
un moment où on était branché sur des
musiques où on allait revendiquer euh
des choses la liberté euh et cetera
et puis finalement il y a un moment on
s'est dit euh quand tout ça va reprendre
on va avoir qu'une envie tous c'est bien
s'éclater et de on a eu envie de quelque
chose de joyeux
brillant un peu excentrique et puis il
se trouve que ben moi ça fait partie de
ma culture musicale alors justement vous
venez d'où pardon ah musicalement
musicalement ah là là alors musicalement
de de géographiquement de Bourgogne çaz
compris ement moi je j'ai une route
assez sinueuse je viens de je viens déjà
d'une d'une famille où en terme de de
musique c'était très populaire ce qu'on
écoutait beaucoup deou chansons chansons
française variété et cetera mais aussi
avec des détours vers vers vers vers le
rock vers le vers le régaet je sais pas
en écouté beaucoup de choses j'ai
toujours chanté depuis que j'ai 10 ans
11 ans j'ai commencé à chanter dans des
choral j'ai eu la chance d'être dirigé
bien bien drivé par par des gens super
et j'ai commencé on va dire par le la
musique sacrée le champ classique ça a
été ma première d' expérience en tant
que soliste aussi après je suis arrivée
en fac d'anglais où là j'étais parti
euh pour pour enseigner enfin c'était
mon idée première et puis j'ai eu la
mauvaise idée idée de rencontrer euh
beaucoup de musiciens
et donc au bout de au bout d'un an je
faisais quasiment plus de la musique
donc je suis passé par les musiques
afro-américaines le gospel les Spirit la
la d'anglais ça permet aussi deis ça ça
permet plein de choses voilà et puis ça
voilà c'est aussi cette cette ouverture
vers vers cette culture britannique et
cette culture musicale britannique voilà
alors cela dit là c'est la culture
britannique mais vous avez fait dougarou
qui était la culture
française si même si elle est très
jazz dans la musique c'était
franco-américaine oui c'est ça c'était
c'était la rencontre au fond de la
poésie française et du du jazz américain
là çaou là c'est là c'est le le les anpp
de l'Angleterre c'est ça ouais avec quoi
comme
comme dans les groupes ENF dans les al
on a on est on peut difficilement se
départir de ce laisser de côté les
Beatles parce que c'est tellement
central David B let's dance's
dance
euh Queen super trampe ah ouais douche
Kate Bush Nick Drake Nick
drakeut Sting police Police Sting les
deux de génial donc c'est en fait vous
prenez votre pied là non pas mal on
s'est vraiment vraiment amusé à monter
ça vraiment au sens
premier c'est compliqué
musicalement ce qui ce qui était ce qui
n'a comment dire ce qui a pas été
toujours simple c'était de de vraiment
s'extraire des originaux parce que on on
écoute des chansons sont tellement
parfaites ou ça parce que parce que ce
que vous faites aussi enfin voilà c'est
c'est vous partez des des des partition
et ça mais mais vous y apportez votre
votre votre vision votre
votreout votre âme quoi he aès on les
traite voilà nous euh ce qui nous anime
tout de suite suite en fait c'est c'est
ce côté très très libre du jazz et puis
de l'improvisation et votre votre
liberté à vous a voilà et que ce soit un
standard de jazz
ou que ce soit un stand de jazz ou un
ugaro ou même les les les classiques
qu'on a fait ou la popr qu'on est en
train de faire maintenant bah c'est de
prendre un thème et puis de vite partir
ailleurs quoi je rappelle humblement que
les toutes tous les standards de jazz
sont des chansons c'est vrai je le
rappelle c'est B pardon Sandrine je je
enfin je sais pas si c'est possible ou
pas est-ce qu'à capella vous pourriez
nous faire un un petit
t capella du matin capella du matin ou
c'est bien on fait travailler les graves
c'est vrai vous pouvez pourous allez
pour nous donner on peu quelque chose de
calme
ouais un morceau de Queen
[Musique]
Queen place for
us this word has only one sweet
moment yes set aside for
us who
want
to
Forever who
des to
Forever bravo merci
merci je sais même pas si je'était pas
comme ça
derrière là en fait il y en a il y en a
plusieurs comme ça où justement on a
celui-là par exemple bon on va dévoiler
un petit peu le le notre cheminement
pour pour celui-là par exemple il y a
c'est c'est un morceau c'est la bande
c'est la BO de Highlander cette chanson
d'accord donc il y a quelque chose de
c'est pas quelque chose c'est carrément
grand presque grandil loquant il y a des
arrangements symphoniques arrangements
symphoniques dans dans cette chanson
donc nous on trio qu'est-ce que vous
voulez on peut pas lutter donc à partir
du moment où partant de là ben notre
notre carte à jouer c'est de jouer
totalement le l'antipole l'antipode
pardon l'antipode de ça c'est-à-dire la
la l'intimité la quelque chose de de
mais mais qui mais qui vient de nous
quand
même prre contrepied puis on cherche
pardon je t'ai coupé on cherche aussi à
à à travers notre travail d'arrangement
c'estàdire qu'on on bosse plutôt tous
les trois ensemble ensemble sur sur ce
répertoire bah après il peut arriver
qu'il y en a un qui arrive en disant
voilà j'ai fait un arrangement comme
c'est le cas sur imagine par exemple
pour Damien mais ce qui est sympa c'est
qu'on prend le morceau on prend le texte
aussi enfin moi je suis hyper attachée à
au histoires qu'on qu'on
raconte et c'est vrai que tout de suite
en fait ça nous aide à prendre prendre
une direction alors soit on va prendre
complètement le contrepied soit par
exemple on prend un morceau de Kate Bush
que tout le monde connaît qui s'appelle
withering Heights qui qui a qui est très
épique et voilà et donc bah quand on se
met à parler de l'histoire voilà cette
cette femme qui le fantôme de cette
femme qui revient par la fenêtre pour
dire à son à son chéri bon je crois que
j'ai pas fini le job VI faut qu'on parle
il y a un moment où bah David voilà on
lui dit là tu vas tu vas pas faire un
cor du batterie tu tu vas t'enfuir dans
les bras dans les bois tu tu vas
traverser une rivière puis tu vas tomber
puis tu vas t'accrocher puis tu vas te
griffer et puis ça ça se traduit
rythmiquement scè
rymiement vous racontez des histoires
quoi exactement
ou ouais bon ben génial alors bah je je
rappelle quand même que
ça'appelle dance et c'est
donc ce vendredi au théâtre Alphonse
Daudet à coagère mais que c'est compli
enfin essayez on sais pas sil y a
peut-être quelqu'un qui va JIS voilà il
peut-être une place qui va se libérer
oui oui faites le savoir si vous voulez
on aura l'occasion on se reverra ce
qu'on essera de faire c'est de d'aller
peut-être vir venir nous voir filmer on
vous invite on vous invite à la balance
ouais ça sera bien ça sera ou au concert
si vous pouvez au concert merci à
merci infiniment voil on dit
merde
dit
voil merci merci David
pour